[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm stephanie wong a developer
advocate here at google and today i'm
going to talk to you about pi
well
actually we're talking about the
mathematical number here but let's use
this apple pie to illustrate the new
world record of pi calculation we just
set
this little bit here represents 1
trillion digits
well using google cloud's compute engine
we calculated 100 trillion digits of pi
adding more than 37 trillion digits to
the previous record set in 2021. another
way to think about it if you had 100
trillion of these toy bricks you could
build the entire great wall of china and
still have 39 trillion bricks to spare
of course you might be asking why
calculate trillions of digits of pi when
you only need dozens of digits for
scientific purposes
well calculating pi has been one of the
best ways to measure human progress in
calculations over the last several
decades
in 1949 one of the first electronic
computers eniac calculated
2037 decimal places of pi
since then scientists and engineers all
around the world have worked to get to
as many digits as possible the jump from
2000 to 100 trillion shows how much
faster our computers and algorithms have
become over the last several decades
we calculated pi twice using google
cloud the first time was in 2019 when we
hit 31.4 trillion decimals
this year we calculated 100 trillion
decimals more than three times our
previous world record
this means our cloud infrastructure such
as virtual machines network and storage
improved to handle even more data
and even though we calculated three
times more digits we only spent 157 days
or 30 percent more time than that 121
days it took to get to 31.4 trillion
digits
so
how did we run the numbers exactly
we used a program called y cruncher
developed by alexander yi
it runs on a single virtual machine just
like a web server
it's just extremely compute storage and
memory intensive
so we used an n2 high mem128 compute
engine instance with 128 vcpus and
864 gigabytes of memory it is one of the
largest virtual machines you can use on
google cloud
y cruncher uses both memory and disks to
store data during the calculation and
100 trillion digits requires about 515
terabytes of storage the maximum
capacity you can attach to a single vm
is 257 terabytes so we needed to get a
little creative to add more disks
we used a storage protocol called iscsi
to mount additional disks to a virtual
machine
with iscsi you can use a remote drive
just like your local ssd
we had a total capacity of 663 terabytes
spanning across 32 n2 high cpu 16 vms
each with two 10.4 terabyte persistent
disks
iscsi uses a standard tcpip protocol to
communicate with storage nodes the n2
highmem128 compute node has 100 gigabits
per second bandwidth up from 16 gigabits
per second in 2019 and this increase
helped run the calculation much faster
than the last time
we also used a new type of persistent
disk called balanced pd
balance pd offers up to 1200 megabytes
per second read and write throughput and
15 to 80 000 iops for about sixty
percent of the cost of ssdpds
this storage profile is a sweet spot for
y cruncher which needs high throughput
and medium iops this reduced the overall
storage cost significantly
we tried many different parameters
before coming up with this particular
configuration
we used terraform to manage virtual
machines so that we could try different
configurations quickly
we also developed a small ruby script to
test why cruncher with various
parameters too which helped us test
about a hundred different combinations
of settings in about a week
the final design was about twice as fast
as our first design which means the
calculation could have taken twice as
long without all the measurements and
optimizations
we also wrote a few shell scripts to
automate backups and restores during the
calculation
backups are automatically taken every
two days as persistent as snapshots
unlike regular disk copies pd snapshots
happen in the background which means the
calculation needs to pause for a few
seconds and resume quickly while the
compute engine infrastructure copies the
data blocks asynchronously
this feature minimizes the downtime for
the backups letting us run the script as
often as needed without performance
penalty
backups are only useful though when you
can actually restore data from them so
we tested the resource script and made
sure that we were able to restart from
one of the backups
we deleted and recreated the virtual
machines as if all data were lost
this practice gave us the confidence and
the preparations we made because we knew
the calculations would take months
instead of days the scripts we used are
all available on github so check out the
link in the description if you want to
learn more about automation after
running the program for five months we
got the result
but it's not the end of the story there
is no way of knowing whether the answer
was correct until we verified it with
another algorithm at the end
and this was one of the scariest moments
during the project because the time you
spent might end up with some random
numbers instead of pi
fortunately the answers did match and
the results were valid
the total amount of data we read and
wrote was 82 petabytes and the
infrastructure got every bit correct
for reference that's almost 820 000
2-hour 4k movies
i think this is a good example of the
reliability of the cloud infrastructure
if you want to see the digits of pi we
have an api and demos you can play with
at pi.delivery check out the link in the
description below
you can get any numbers between 3.14 and
the 100 trillionth digit 0.
you can also visualize and listen to pi
there
for more record-breaking fun cloud
content subscribe to the google cloud
tech channel
oh you thought i wasn't gonna eat this
pipe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]